PROFESSOR: We're
constantly asking how long
we have to wait for things.
And in the context of
probability theory,
it turns into the
technical question called,
the expected time to failure--
or the mean time to failure.
Some examples might be that
an insurance company wants
to know, for a
given policy holder,
the expected time before
that policy holder dies.
A mechanical engineer wants
to know the expected time
before a button that's
being pushed once per second
is expected to fail.
And I want to know when
the part that my body
shop has been waiting for
is expected to come in.
The mean time to
failure problem,
we can formalize in
terms of flipping coins.
So we're going to flip a
coin until a head comes up.
And we're going
to think of a head
as being a failure, and
a tail as a success.
So let's assume the
probability of getting a head--
the probability
of failure-- is p.
Again, this is not a fair coin.
It's a coin that may be
biased in either direction.
And let's let F be
the number of flips
until the first head comes
up-- the number of flips
until the first failure.
And if we're counting as flips
as time, it's the time to fail.
So what we'd like to know is
what's the expectation of F?
What's the expected number of
flips before a head comes up?
Well, in order to
calculate that expectation,
we need to know
some probabilities.
So what's the probability
that F equals 1?
Well that's the same
as saying that that's
getting a head on
the first flip-- it's
the probability that you get
just an H on the first flip,
and that has probability, P.
What's the probability
that F equals 2?
Well that's the probability
that you flip a tail and then
a head.
And that has
probability q times p,
because we're assuming
the flips are independent,
so it's the probability
of a tail-- which
is q-- times the probability
of a head-- which is p.
Similarly, the
probability of F equals
3 is the same as the probability
of flipping tail, tail, head--
and it's q squared p.
And of course, the
probability density function
of F-- the number
of steps until you'd
flip a head-- at
n-- the probability
that you have to flip n times
before you get the first head--
is q at the n minus 1 p.
By the way, a random variable
whose probability density
function is this value is
called a geometric distribution.
They come up all the time.
All right, so what's the formula
for the expectation of F?
It's simply, of
course, by definition,
it's the sum over all the
possible values of F--
which in this case are
integers, n, greater than 0,
of n times the probability
that F equals n.
We figured out that the
probability that F equals n
is q to n minus 1 times p.
And now I'm going to
observe that we really
do know how to evaluate
this sum easily enough.
I'm going to factor
out the p, and it
becomes a sum over n
greater than 0 of q
to the n minus 1 times n.
And then I can simplify matters
if I replace n by n minus 1.
And then I get a
q to the n power.
So this is equivalent to
p times the sum over n
greater than or equal to
0 of n plus 1 q to the n.
Now this is a familiar
generating function.
It's simply equal to 1
over 1 minus q squared,
as we've seen already.
So in short, the expectation
of F is p times 1
over the square of 1 minus q.
So let's put them
together, there.
Of course 1 minus q is
p, so it's p times 1
over p squared, or one over p.
And we get this really
very clean answer.
The expected number
of flips before you
get a head is 1 over the
probability of a head.
So for example, with a
fair coin, where p is 1/2,
the expected number of flips
until you get the first head
is 2-- it's 1 over 1/2.
If you had a biased coin, where
the probability of getting
a head was 1 in 3--
1/3-- then, in fact,
the expected number of flips
until you got a head was 3.
OK, that's a nice clean answer.
But we got it in this
way that doesn't really
give much intuition.
So let's look at
another naive way
to derive the expected
time to the first head,
without having to worry
about generating functions,
and all that sophisticated
stuff about series-- which
is easy to forget.
So let's look at the
outcome tree that
describes this
experiment of flipping
until you get the first head.
So starting at the
root, with probability,
p, you flip a head
immediately and you stop.
Or, with probability,
q, you flip a tail,
and then with probability,
p, you finally flip the head
and stop.
If you haven't flipped the head
by the end of the second step,
then that is a possibility
that, with probability, q,
flipped a tail, and then
there's a possibility
that you stop after the third
step, with a head, and so on.
That's how this tree goes.
Now, looking at the
structure of this tree,
it's an infinite tree,
but it's very repetitive.
In fact, if we call it the
tree B, then what we're seeing
is that this whole
sub-tree is a copy of B.
So now I have a nice
recursive, but very finite,
description of this
whole infinite tree.
B is a tree that has a
left branch of p that
ends in a leaf, or a right
branch with probability,
q, followed by a
repeat of the tree, B.
So now I can apply
total expectation
to find the expectation of F. F
is the expected number of steps
I make in this tree until I
finally make the left branch
to an H. How do
I figure out what
the expected time in the tree
is until I make that left branch
of flipping a head, finally?
Well, using total
expectation, what I can do
is branch on whether or not
the first flip is a head.
So the expectation
of F, according
to the total
expectation is going
to be the expectation
of F, given
that the first flip is a head,
times the probability, p,
that it is a head.
And the other term is that it's
the expectation of F, given
that the first flip is a
tail times q, the probability
that the first flip is a tail.
Well, first of all,
let's look at this term.
What is the expected
number of flips
until you get a head,
given that you got a head?
Well, it's 1.
So this term is
easily taken care of.
We understand that one.
What about this term?
This is the expected
number of flips
until you get the first tail.
Sorry-- it's the
expected number of flips
until you get the first head,
given that your first step was
a tail.
Well what that means is that
we are here after the tail,
and we're asking,
what's the expectation
of F-- the number
of flips that you
get starting at B-- when you
do one flip that takes you
to the start of B again?
And the answer is, obviously,
1 plus the expected number
of flips in B,
which is expectation
of F. In short, this term--
the expectation of F, given
that the first flip
is a tail, is simply
1 plus the expected
number of flips
that we're trying to figure out.
Now look at this-- I have a very
simple arithmetic formula now.
Expectation of F is 1 times
p plus 1 plus F times q.
There it is.
And now I can solve
for E of F. Well,
just taking a
quick look at this,
this is going to yield a
q term, and p plus q is 1.
And this is going to be q times
E of F, and there's an E of F
there.
If I pull the E of
F over, I'm going
to do a little
arithmetic-- I'm going
to leave the rest to
you, and realize, again,
that the answer is what we had
before, the expectation of F
is equal to 1 over p.
So let's do one more
silly example for fun
to remember what the
significance of 1 over p is.
[? Suppose we think ?]
about the space station Mir.
Now, it's spinning around,
and there's a lot of garbage
out there that it's likely
to hit-- a lot of space junk.
And suppose that, based
on our previous statistics
and estimations of the small
stuff that has been hitting Mir
that it could survive, that we
estimate that there's about a 1
in 150,000 chance that
in any given hour,
it's going to run
into some intolerable
collision with space junk, or a
meteor that's going to destroy.
So suppose the space
station Mir has a 1
in 150,000 chance of
destruction in any given hour.
So how many hours do we
expect until destruction?
Well, it's 1 of over
150,000, 150,000 hours,
which [INAUDIBLE]
So much for silly
space station examples.
Let's wrap up with an intuitive
argument that could be made
rigorous, but I'm not going to,
because I think it's clearer
just left in this informal
way that makes it intuitive
why you would expect
that, of course,
the expected time
to failure is 1
over the probability of
failing on a given flip.
Well, how many failures
do we expect in one try?
Well, by definition,
it's the expectation
of getting a head on
the first flip-- it's p.
OK, now if you flip
n times, you expect
to get n times as many failures
as you'd expect in one try.
So the expected number of
fails in n tries is n times p.
That's an intuitive argument.
In fact, it's the
rigorously correct argument.
Remember that if
we flip n times,
we're counting the number
of heads and flips--
that's a binomial
distribution we already
figured out in a
couple of ways--
that it's expectations is n p.
But never mind that.
I think it's intuitively
clear that if you expect
p heads in one try, and you do n
tries that are all independent,
you're going to expect to get
n times p failures-- or heads.
Now, what's the expected number
of tries between failures?
Well if you think about
that, I've done n tries,
and I've got n p failures, so
if I divide the number of tries
by the number of failures,
that, by definition, is
the average time
between the failures.
It's the expected
time to a failure.
So I divide the number of tries
by the number of fails-- which,
by definition, is the
average number of tries
between failures, and it's
equal to n over n p, which
is equal to 1 over p.
And that's an argument that
I hope you will remember.